welcome to this video perrito we are all
from Brazil okay never played this a
chaste guy reform you should be fraught
check this is the Sun God Karros defense
it's a bit uncommon to play it with them
c5 this is not the regular Bhogle Indian
the night moves are not not played and
the bogo there's no default possible
okay I'm just developing normally here
and see what is coming up with something
with d5 maybe no with f5 oh wow really
it looks very weakening
so
you're saying that after this what what
what is he saying here what is he doing
with his night now I would be businesses
would interest me he cannot take here
what cannot take on d5 for because of
Bishop c4 yes and you really want you to
now go back it looks it looks kind of
kind of dicey moving the night now again
and then I play d6 that looks very risky
that could easily be M mating attack
already with bishops 495 and all those
moves coming quickly I wonder what what
is some what is considering i mean night
hmm we're a five looks absolutely
terrible but it controls c4 maybe this
is some what is his considering however
the night has no square this is this is
really important and move like a three
ask of asks a very awkward kind of
question but still d6s am it's looking
very dangerous hmm yeah it all it's all
good yeah this is this is the real the
real problem for him it's all good for
white a 383 Queen B 6 is just about
holding but it's really not holding
right I can a 3 Queen B 6 takes Queen
takes Queen d2 Queen takes GT two night
ft to whence the night almost be six
before night b7 almost it's very close
but I mean this this cannot be better at
this d6 move is actually moving the
night to g6 so that he has a retreat
square I see the point okay at night
f-4s Sam is a possibility so what if I'm
I just some go form and go for a direct
attack here
hmm ok maybe night f4 this is possible
maybe you can play Knight to f4 b6 know
that that that's not going to that's not
going to work I mean this was the
relatively obvious threat I thought
now that's it he cannot defend now
anything h6 queen 6h takes she five this
Knight f6 check and made it a couple of
moves it's not made oh I'm sorry Knight
f6 rook f6 queen 87 checking f7 what a
shame if I go 95 he has Queenie adium
and he just about prevents the checkmate
how unfair is that ok I'm going to
cancel I don't want the Queen trade
anymore this should really be a maid so
I'm going to continue him yeah now i can
play Knight f6 this was the idea Chad
look takes Queen e8 I had no defense
anyway I was just threatening 95 and I
really don't see how how I should defend
them
this was this was just far too bad
opening results to to get them to get a
decent game jack check checkmate them
the cash defense is pretty okay but c5
fear i'm really not not sure if it is so
if it is any good to allow this efore
move I mean I really don't know but it
looks a bit strange to me that you
should allow that and what really got
problematic is f5 I mean this is just
weakening everything and then this is
this is on the verge of being unplayable
I think I don't know I don't think you
can can really still get a decent
position here txt here and now i played
this 6 yeah i was thinking that a 3 is
interesting but I thought that Queen B 6
just about just about save some this yes
this was my line Jake stakes and be 64
be 497 unfortunately and he saves the
piece it looks still weird but it's not
not that brilliant her wide obviously
gym and now KD 6 cannot be bad really
and now I went for this direct attack
vb6 it's just like just ignoring
everything that that this move is
representing I thought night f4 might be
might be tricky I would have Castle jam
and h6 mmm yeah cancels age 6
computer points out this this is funny
check just just this year attacking you
and black has no no defense wyd wins IAM
interesting and I'll be okay after that
I'm just I'm just winning with exactly
what I played I guess yeah tried f6 yeah
this is opening is this really risky I
mean to put it mildly maybe it is more
than risky okay well thanks for watching